okay so as most of you know since I know
all of you I played in the Michigan open
a couple weeks ago and I showed them
something not sure what I showed them I
showed them that I old and weak but I
have good fodder for the class because
I'm his father
okay so in round one I played a very
instructive game because I won I was
white and you saw this position today in
both games that's why I did this so I
would prepare you for today's games now
gotta play Knight f3 ridiculous and
Carlson played c4 now knock and we're
played g6 which is the King's Indian
eventually my opponent played east six
and now I allow the nimzo-indian was
Bishop to b4 which pins the knight right
Liam yeah but my opponent didn't play
Bishop to b4 which pins my knight which
is most of my games I have a lot of
nimzo-indian x' instead my opponent play
d5 which transposes into another opening
what's this opening called Grandmaster
Ken West if you sit closer you can see
and trying to knock over the tripod
Queen's Gambit right
I was I was thinking that too
yeah well some people might want to play
the benoni
and then they don't probably going to
get slight c3 but I doubt that was his
reason okay so yeah it's strange to play
this move order usually just play d5 I
move one okay so I pinned his Knight and
black has many moves in this position he
could play Bishop to b4 Knight B to d7
c6h6 losing upon Bishop e7 is the most
common
also I've played c5 which is crazy talk
that's really interesting okay this is
the normal now Liam where did I develop
my bishop I can't move it
but I noticed I couldn't move it so I
played III now I could move it and I
defended my pawn so if he takes my pawn
I'll take back which did not happen and
he castled and I played this okay who
knows what the most common move for
black is in this position you incorrect
but good answer that would be the
Orthodox defense which I faced many
times but more common is you incorrect
what incorrect well this isn't a media
class not absolutely not
very good Grandmaster gets the right
answer what a surprise
age six which was not played you
incorrect absolutely not absolutely not
now after eight six Bishop age four
black can play the Tartar collar maca
GaN dog with b6 or the Lasker with 94
but my opponent agreed with Spencer and
played b6 now I can't put the NC chowder
collar because he played b6 he showed me
now a problem with b6 is after I develop
my Bishop to castle and he develops his
bishop my opponent is going to take my
pawn and have a nice open bishop the
normal Tariq our position would be this
position and this position one way for
White's the play is to take tonight and
then take the pawn it's not the only way
to play that's pretty common and if
you're as old as I am right Liam now
you're not as old as me if you're as old
as I am
you've member
all of the games from the Karpov
coronally Karpov Kasparov matches where
we saw these positions especially when
coronary was white and Karpov was black
and in those games we saw a lot of
Bishop takes us like basically what I
did
except this had already been thrown in
so black already had left for his King
and so forth it's not a big difference
but I like those positions for white so
I took the night why did I take the
night thanks for asking because if I
take the pawn right away my opponent
won't take with the pawn he'll take with
a night trading lots of pieces and then
he'll have an open bishop this bishop
will have a nice open diagonal and if
you're a connoisseur of World
Championship chess like ken west then
you'll know the last game in the Lasker
between an on and topalov where black
one with this nice bishop on the
diagonal and crushing attack do to top a
lot of dead play okay so I take the
knight and he takes the bishop and now
he won't play Knight takes d5 because
there's no night there it's good reason
so so I took and he took with a pawn and
now the only active play for black at
the center is c5 however c5 is not
recommended because it's not his move
that because he just took back but he
plays c5 he could start attacking my
center so I played b4 and I've actually
had white and black in this position but
not at the same time and when I have
white and black normally this move is
thrown in already that's slightly
different now you can play c6 or c5 my
opponent was not familiar with this
opening because he sat and thought
forever on every move they had no idea
what to do and he eventually played c5
one of my students said that was a bad
move because I have two pawns attacking
his one defending that student is lower
rated than me so after pawn takes pawn
pawn takes pawn
Liam do you think white should play pawn
takes pawn what do you think it's
recommended by Grandmaster Ken West so
probably not that's usually a bad sign
now the taking is wrong because the
netra Bishop takes Knight check I would
struggle to draw struggle but probably
lose okay now again I've had this
position with white and black but with
the pawn h6 and white plays rook to be
one which does several things my
favorite thing that it does is detects
the bishop the second thing it does it
puts the rook on an open file third
thing it gets it off his diagonal where
the bishop can capture my ruck now one
of my greatest victories from a personal
standpoint was against international
master leonid bass oh you've never heard
of including you heard of him yes II
told you and I was quite young 14 and
that was one of the first items I ever
beat and I had black in this position
again with the pawn here and I played
Queen to a5 which most grandmasters
don't think is very good most
grandmasters play Bishop to c6 because
the bishop is attacked so they move it
away and catalyst is furiously taking
notes pieces attacks move them away and
Queen a5 the counter attacks this piece
okay but my opponent played a third move
a move I was not familiar with for
obvious reasons it's not a good move
okay he played Queen c7 and that that
defends his Bishop so if I take his
Bishop he takes my rug
but that breaks a lot of rules that I
teach although I think Carlsen Nakamura
Aronian and calm ski break every rule I
teach every move okay
that's why they're all doing terrible so
while you're putting your queen on a
half-open file so it could be harassed
by the rook and you're also putting your
queen on a square that would be exposed
to my knight to b5 which actually
happens later okay well i castled
because i that's what I do when I play
chess i castle
and if my opponent takes my pawn I could
take back either way but I was planning
on playing Knight to b5 attacking his
queen and then he would be left with
this isolated pawn my opponent played a
strange move I thought he played Rick
FCA's what is that logic see it actually
is that a good move he makes a battery
okay and then I made a good move so they
thought I was cheating with the computer
because they never saw you make a good
move
I play Queen b3 which again does several
things in a text to Bishop on b7 and
attacks the pawn on d5 and it protects
my knight and whites almost winning here
because I have a lot of threats and my
opponents can have a lot of weak pawns
my opponent took which is very
complicated so I made the worst move
ever which maintains a slight advantage
but I probably have a clear advantage
here and there were three logical moves
and I chose the worst so that way the
game went longer which is good for my
lecture so according to the computer the
best move is nine takes d5 okay and that
I guess makes sense okay and then I'm
attacking everything and the second best
move is Knight takes d4 and the idea is
if he takes my knight I'll take his
bishop which makes sense
I played the third best move Knight to
b5 and that's the safest way to get an
advantage because I give him an isolated
pawn with his bishop blocking blocked by
his pawn well unlike a lot of the people
in this class today
he saw his Queen was attacked and played
Queen to d7 and I I took actually with
the F Knight strange for me yeah what's
wrong with me but I like my Knights
okay my opponent plating move I didn't
see which I'm going to say a lot today
because I didn't see all my opponent
play nine a six probably not a good move
what's that yeah ah very good 986 right
and if you say it three times then you
can claim a draw although if Chris Berg
was here he would deny okay now I made a
good move because it turns out the
groove that's correct is the kind of
move that I make if it was like a force
to mate with a sacrifice then I wouldn't
make it if it was the only winning move
then I wouldn't make it if it was a
subtle move that nobody could understand
then I wouldn't make it but this is my
kind of move what incorrect double
question mark actually that might be
double question mark Knight c5 I was
kidding but maybe it is a bad move yeah
but then I use your knight yeah okay so
there's certain kind of moves that I
like okay nobody else likes them so
usually when I play them they're
surprised okay and those moves are
retreats you'll notice a young player in
the audience I don't know who probably a
low-rated player suggest to the move
that went forward possibly losing the
game but I like to go backwards because
then you know you're safe now
there was an acquaintance of mine in
Michigan and many many years ago and he
said don't put your pieces in the center
they could get hurt there okay and he
made a lot of sense just not on that
particular statement or anything else he
ever said okay but but he's right the
further you are the more likely you'll
be captured now my opponent's next move
when he played 96 was to play Knight c5
attacking my queen and possibly 94 now I
like to notice things for example my
opponent has isolated pawns and my
opponent doesn't have love for his King
either do why another thing that I
noticed is my opponents queen and rook
are lined up diagonally and that's a
tactical thing that I noticed so for
example the way the Queen and rooks are
Knight b6 will be a very strong move
except he could play pawn takes Knight
and I don't have a knight if you go to
b6 I don't see why that should stop me
all those issues but they do now since I
can't play Knight b6 in its protected
his queen rooks lined up for that fork
don't really matter however his Queen
rook lined up for this skewer do matter
and or does matter and so I played Age 3
is actually a very good move because I
get left and I prepare Bishop g4 but
that's not a retreat I like to retreat
that's why I speak French so often to
prepare to retreat exactly you got that
job okay
so I played Queen to d1 okay anybody got
cheese oh wait a minute
ah a period a fool ah I can't get it ah
yay okay and where's my endorsement
checks okay so I play Queen to d1
because now my Queen and Bishop make
battery so I'm threading this g4 and
ninety five doesn't attack my Queen
which didn't stop him he played nine c5
I played Bishop g4 a skewering his queen
in he resigned thank you for enjoying my
lecture now he played 96 that's why he
played Knight to c5 okay now White has a
winning combination and I played the
first couple of moves isn't that enough
why should I play the actual
continuation I took the night expecting
him to recapture and I was correct
Bishop take that yes and he would have
also won but okay and then 94 and I'm
attacking a six and I'm threatening
Bishop takes EE 6 with advantage right
yeah
now King f7 this is a good way to defend
and rookie doesn't work because the
Queen like most of the GM's the
tournament right now is overloaded okay
the queen is defending the e6 pawn and
it's the Fang the bishop on b7 so if I
captured on e6 and we kept capturing his
queen would go there and I would take
his bishop so 48 doesn't work and King
f7 doesn't work what did he do to save
his e6 pawn anyone you incorrect yes
correct this should take d4 okay getting
rid of my attacking piece okay now I
have a combination which wins upon but I
have a good excuse for not playing it
yes that's correct and if I did see it
then I would have played it so and again
this is the overloaded theme but usually
when somebody takes you recapture like
Barney the Dinosaur right I take you you
take me right see he agrees
so don't sue me don't sue me
okay so dinosaur consume me I'll beat
him now what I should do is make the
Queen move away from the pawn with the
obvious move Canwest
ripped but I'm not as strong a
Grandmaster as Grand Master Ken West
okay and check it if I worked for
several hours otherwise the smell is
different that's why I'm not as strong
Queen takes b7 Bishop takes East six
check the King would move I guess not
Queen upsome Bishop takes rook he would
take my bishop and I would take his
bishop and I would be a pawn ahead and
he would have two isolated pawns I would
win fairly routinely with my brilliant
technique
in six hours okay and then white is a
pawn up but I didn't play it because I
didn't see it I need to do more tactical
puzzles or something out of that this is
here okay so King so instead I took the
bishop now with the Queen but with the
pawn so I could open up this line to his
II pawn and get tremendous pressure
which I did he need some move I don't
know yeah tricky a defending his pawn
riki one attacking his pawn which is
already defended dish up a six because
the Queen is defending both so he's had
enough of that now what move would you
make with white to enhance your pressure
on e6 okay because you don't want your
advantage to fizzle BAM you you're
supposed to laugh at that what Queen e2
is risky because he might play Bishop
takes Queen
if he doesn't though then I would take
his bishop and I would win now they tell
you a funny story I had a student whose
name I won't mention
stand back with and he moved his Queen
and it was hanging to the other guy's
Queen so that was not good there's
opponent rated about the same 1800 made
some random move and then my student
like Queen takes Queen he wanted Queen
somebody was going to win a queen turned
on I was my student yeah so he's
sacrificing no not he just didn't see
Queen takes Queen after the guy movies
like wait a minute our Queens are
opposing each other
that's top level chess you
I did not who are you playing better
than me
you want to go here but I did that later
now I have this truck attacking the pawn
I want my other rook attack in the pawn
what's that rogue to be three and then
if Jen shaadi wasn't Saint Louis what
she is she would say this is a row over
because my rook goes up and over her a
rook b3 and then my opponent not here to
resign he played here rook to e7 solid I
played this he he made it with which I'm
really unhappy he made because I can't
reach it
rook to e8 now his rooks are really
active except they're not active okay so
that's terrible
and then I played a move that I was
taught back in the day so if you've been
following a chess tournament and you've
been watching gotta calm skews
unfortunate play come on why isn't he
here oh well that's funnier if he's here
you'll notice gada unlike most chess
players like to play h4 h5 h6 and
vice-versa H 5 H 4 H 3 and then he
doesn't win any games because that's
terrible
but when I do it it's good and that's
why I'm teaching now and he's somewhere
they'll tell crying probably ok so in
this position I'm doing a good job it's
hacking here but he's just defending it
so I have to attack somewhere else
I played h4 I'm going to push my H pawn
got a calm ski style and then my King
has a lift square in case he mates me
and H fortunate out to win the game for
me because he played incredibly badly
against it
notice how his pawn is pinned so e5 is
not recommended although it's often
suggested the D inter-class because I
would take his Queen he played Queen to
d6 now if Spencer was white what would
he play Spencer
correct and now the pawn can't move
otherwise you would have play d5 right
now he play that move so bad that I'm so
mad yeah this reminds me of two - Soviet
grandmasters who are now American
they're from the old school
it's so old nobody knows Alex you're
mullinski and Roman gin Josh feely those
are the only grandmasters I know who are
mad when their opponent plays badly
because they're ruining a good game of
chess why are you playing so bad I'm
trying to play a good game of chess here
most people they want their opponents to
play badly so they win right Liam yeah
you're like ah he played badly I'm
waiting yay Brett yeah when you play
badly against them they're like why are
you playing dead I'm trying to play a
good game of chess here so my opponent
played of moving that ilk right he
played a move that's just terrible right
if the car was walking around here he
would look at the move shake his head
walk away okay but as long as he doesn't
take my periods okay okay he played the
worst strategical move of all time cause
that would be the worst tactical move of
all time g6 there's a guy who's a bad
strategical player yeah I got a call on
me g6 if it was blacks turn to move here
he should play g7 okay now his King is
safe so I'm trying to attack his King
and he's like okay here you can check me
me so you don't want to move pawns in
front of your King unless you're playing
me then do it okay h5 and now he's
probably losing now so he played another
move the crowd was suggesting came to f7
terrible okay now I can actually win
immediately by sacrificing material like
taking and Bishop h5 I'm not doing that
so I played Queen to d2 I put all of my
pieces on dark squares because his
bishops on a white square so that way he
won't take it Julian incorrect
correct we have Jack King moves Queen
here
yeah Bishop CA maybe so when I play
Queen d2 I thought it was obvious what I
wanted to do but it wasn't obvious to my
opponent if what's that I wanted to play
Queen aged six and then I win I thought
he might stop that or prepare to stop it
or something
but he ignored it he played the super
aggressive Bishop c8 setting up for the
next game right jerk exactly
so I played Queen aged six and this is
how old I am I thought there was no
legal way to not lose a part I didn't
see how you I'm threatening this nice
wealthy plays King g8 this puns hanging
he plays rook h8 I can take and it's
pinned so I was like hey I'm winning
upon and I'm mating him and then he made
a move I didn't see because I don't look
at moves like this very crafty King f6
defending both pawns right where the
King belongs okay and oh this is a game
that I'd be a Magnus a few years of nom
kid okay so normally when I have a
winning position if I recognize it's
winning like this one I try to imagine
how I will win so for example when I was
playing a blindfold simultaneous against
Magnus and LaVon yesterday I had to
imagine how I would win and then
apotheca but it said congenital heart
defect affecting both players sends him
to the hospital
I win okay and then I was able to win
the games okay and if you if you're one
of the Simpsons writers don't sue me
okay so I imagine if I had a rook on the
F file that would give me the advantage
due to it being checkmate so I played
rook to e3 threatening rook f3 checkmate
with advantage now he should move is he
want he needs a square for his King
heats a move that rook that way and then
he's - Allah
right okay affect the numbers are so
high it's more for the advanced class
it's too high for people in this class
he played Warcraft seven which is quite
bad I checked he played the best legal
move kingi seven also the only legal I
took he played the best legal move well
actually the King D it's better now King
takes I I played Queen takes check now
he was worried about King f8 because I
would take this and he didn't like that
position for some reason it's hard to
avoid meeting one who would like to
avoid meeting the one who can do it yes
hey you avoided meeting one yeah better
than I could do Queen seven is me yeah
okay
Riki 7 is also made ok so so he played
King to f6 again and he claimed to draw
and it was an American arbiter so I was
a close call but he said King f6 has
only played twice so it's not a draw no
no that actually happened ok now your
typical gawking Ravel chess player would
either play queen g6 or hg 6 okay but I
am the atypical gawking rebel chess
player okay they pay me to lecture now
again I want to meet my opponent so this
was bughouse I would put a pawn here or
a bishop here or I would ask Levon
Aronian not yes or Sarah one okay
because you know LaVon would know the
answer and this position I tried to
figure out how I could checkmate my
opponent it said Spencer's you already
know the answer Joe possibly forgetting
he's like I didn't forget ridiculous
right they are not allowed to suggest
the winning move and it's the only
winning move into position no I'm
kidding everyone finds did I show you
this you okay you
how good I didn't tell you because you
didn't get it right
this room is recommended by Houdini and
Boris lot even I would definitely play
it 100 percent when I play it he could
prove on my chin because every other
move I made was wrong this is my only
Houdini move of the game
this move is in too good of shape if
somebody plays it so you want to
checkmate black because then you win so
then I did that you correct I want to
play rook g6 mate moving like a rook
which a lot of my kids in chess can't
play right back me up see he's like yeah
okay so so I played rook g5 threatening
rook g6 mate with advantage my opponent
resigned if he didn't resign he would
probably take the rook and I would check
and I want to play Queen takes g6 check
with his King here not with his King
here because then he could run away and
he'd probably beat me two pawns down now
king of four allows me to one which I
would have played king h4 I do this it's
not make as he can give his Queen away
and now I was planning on taking his
rook but computer announces mate somehow
I don't know like this ship somewhere
nobody knows mate in three or four it's
me but I don't know how because I'm old
yeah somewhat I would have taken this
and then I probably would win Lana I
played pretty bad now so then then he
resigned and I won right
what who who only 19 right okay so that
game I liked that game I already showed
in class last week I believe okay that
was a disaster that was the worst game
ever that was even worse I had a
position and I wanted to talk about
table bases because nothing is more fun
than table bases right okay so the way
they're solving chess now is they're
watching all of Grandmaster Ken West's
games and they're not doing any of that
then they solve Jess no no they wouldn't
do that no because that would be mean so
they wouldn't do that it's quicker than
what they're doing now but so okay so
the way they solve chess is they're
using table bases where they're solving
chess piece by piece
how many pieces start a chess game in
total can last thirty two so if you had
a yeah sixteen for you and sixteen for
them yeah so if they're the 32 piece
table base then chess would be solved
then that would be it you guys would
still lose all your games but no solved
okay even when playing each other
now let's restore e okay
now table bases now go to six or seven
pieces so they have a ways to go and I
talk to the table based master also
Grandmaster one of Ross's heroes Ken
Thompson okay the inventor of the
computer and the internet with Al Gore
okay hey you thought that was funny
okay so if you look up Ken Tom's on the
internet you'll notice he's smarter than
you
well he has water-rat yeah also he's a
pilot yeah some of the pictures from
Vegas he was flying the guys around the
two pictures okay and I met him at
Google and I have some friends at Google
and in Mountain View and I said you know
I was talking to
chess and tablebases and such and he
said the guys in Russia are working on
the table bases he says they'll have
eight peace table bases done in twenty
years and that was four or five years
ago and they're finishing seven now
they're almost done so we'll see if they
do eight if he's right and then what's
the it's a 32 we're all set so you know
yeah now but the reason I'm talking
about this is in this tournament I had a
table based position of I can't remember
it oh yeah I was here I had a rook here
he was in check and his pawn can't take
my rook because it's not going that way
so don't suggest that and I had this
position okay
and for those of you who count well
which isn't most of you but some of you
you will tell you will notice that black
has six legal moves three over here and
three over here okay now if you count
the number of pieces including Kings are
you shocked that's includes Kings it's
true how many pieces are on the board
Liam
yeah but in tablebases everything's a
piece including this board not kidding
at the border six so if it's six that
means I can go to the insert blag also
known as the interwebs and I can go to a
website and it tells me the answer
although not during the game although it
would work during the game but not
legally ok and when I went to the
internet after the game it said three of
the moves draw and three of the moves
lose so he had a 50/50 chance but he was
low rated so it's more like zero and
then you can put any position in with
six pieces or last possibly some with
seven and it'll just tell you every
legal move if it wins losses draws or
all three and my opponent shows one of
the losing moves which is good you know
that's good because then I win exactly
exactly
where's my cover when I need them okay
so my opponent picked his king up and I
knew which moves drew him which moves
lost because well I didn't know that
this drew because that's ridiculous but
it does draw and he played here the only
moves that I looked at were king h4 and
King out frightened look another moves
king f4 draws handily and when the game
ended which lasted 5 hours and 45
minutes he said what did I do wrong and
I set this up and I said this draws and
he said how do you know and I said I
checked the tail of aces during the game
no I didn't say that
ok I didn't say I didn't do that but I
didn't say I did ok so I said yeah
there's draws because I calculated it in
a draws really easily so I mean
occasionally I don't need table bases
like if I have a king in five Queens and
you have a king I don't need a table
base I can do it I can figure it out
okay so my upon he would have played
rook a 1 I would have played King here
he could play h5 or he could check me
and then he would play H 4 H 3 H 2 and
it's a really easy draw
now the reason king h4 doesn't draw is
because his king is blocked off and he
can't just push his pawn he has to move
his king several times to get his pawn
down so this actually loses by one tempo
but I have a funny story you know I have
a funny story because I like stories God
because I always have a funny story
exactly so I played a seven and then I
played King to be seven now he should
play rook to be one Shaq and then the
win is actually quite difficult but
instead he played h5 accompanied by a
draw offer okay which was declined and
showing my great analysis of rook and
Bishop versus rook I prefer to a bishop
and he knew I would win with that so he
just took it
no that's not what happened I made a
queen and he took my queen and I took
back and even the most dim-witted
individual with an advanced degree in
hyperbolic topology would tell you this
is easily winning for white black has to
go here and so he did and I moved my
king down the diagonal
rady style he played here I continued
with the radius tile here it's a good
thing I just read the New York 24 book I
really knew rady style well here he was
actually very happy here I could tell he
thought he was going to draw and now he
realized his intended h2 loses to
everything I would have beaten two with
rookie 7 d 7c 7d 7 or a 7 since I can't
reach a 7 I would have played rookie 7
he would play king g1 and I would
probably checkmate well having seen that
I would checkmate him in two moves if he
played H 2 he played King H 2 once again
every move wins except rook G 2 which
wins for black but I played rook age 7
and he resigned hurray
and the table base as I'm winning here
the true story yeah it says white wins
and table
bases are good for several reasons you
may have a king upon ending or some
other kind of ending and you don't know
if you were winning losing or drawing
and your stupid computer says like plus
1.3 for like 20 moves in a row is that I
don't know right
then it says like plus 0.8 and you're
like I don't know but if you go to the
table base it just says like mate in 73
or it says draw like it doesn't it
doesn't give you doesn't give you that
nonsense it just tells you the answer
and I've had to go to the table base
occasionally in 1994 I played in my
first US Championship in what city you
you're my son you have to know I
birthday was last week what when did I
my first US Championship where was it
94 come on you were three no anybody
know what the 90 where's the Aster he
was playing there he cracked the answer
is somewhere in Florida now if you all
know that sheet or a weighted by
actually she could get suit if I said
this well I'll do it anyway so as you
know the cheater well what's her name of
the Nyad the woman who claims she swam
but she's obviously lying Diana Nyad is
that who I'm talking about yeah she slim
110 miles and she's 64 years old in 53
hours without touching anything
that's what happened and she went from
1.5 miles an hour to 3.9 miles an hour
70 miles into the swim that also
happened there was no chant for many
miles that was no cheating involved see
I can't get suit there was no cheat it
was perfectly legitimate okay anyway and
Key West Florida
I played three-time US Champion Nick de
fermion anybody heard of Nick de fermion
and I I was losing the whole game as was
my style at the time and I got to a rook
and Bishop bending down two pawns
instead of resigning I traded all the
pawns and sacked my vision for the other
pawns now I have a funny hot tub story
which actually Liam can hear can you
believe that that's true I was in the
hot tub with you know pinky was
and Boris crybaby crimen said to me do
you know rook and Bishop versus rook and
I said no and he said ah he's a funny
speaking voice and he said you're a
professional player I said I've never
had rookie Bishop versus rook if I have
it it'll cost me half a point in my life
or at Lowen right and he was like rah
okay the very next day I had rook
against trick ambition for the first
time my life and I was like no and my
punts like quiet so I have a rook
against rook and Bishop I ended up
drawing otherwise I never would hear the
end of it and many many many many years
later I went to the table bases because
you can put the position in and turned
out it played perfectly I was always
drawing I showed that guy the following
week I flew to Chicago and Bora my arms
tired and I played international master
Josh Mannion not to be confused with
professional pot Sir Tom Mannion right
friends thank you and I had rook and
Bishop versus rook again because I had
the rook and Bishop and I won and I won
and that was the only two times I ever
had in my life one week apart and that
was 20 years ago
19 years ago I've never had it since
what's that and blitz yeah the Blitz
game is ridiculous
okay so table bases can tell you when
you have rook and Bishop versus rook or
what can I versus rook or rook and pawn
versus rook or some King and pawn 10
games
who's winning and why what the best
moves are and you can check it on the
Internet some of you are doing that
right now and some day when I'm long
gone you'll be able to check 7 8 9 10
peas table bases and you'll see more
complicated positions and since table
bases have been invented they've changed
their mind about some men games like
Queen versus two Knights Queen versus
Bishop Knight and Queen versus two
bishops these endings are weighing about
95% of the time and before that book
said they were drawers but the computers
like now you win and there's some crazy
endgame I think it's rook and Bishop
versus two nights where you win in like
180 moves or something there's some
creepy no computer plays perfect for
both sides if you ever want to test your
acumen at Queen versus rook playing
against the table based computer and see
how you do not good not in too good of
shape yeah and my brother taught me how
to do it but I forgot so now I can't do
it anymore
but I used to be able to do it the
world's leading authority on Queen
versus rook is which Grandmaster Boris
Gelfand
who lectured this chess club two years
ago so I hope he told you that you saw
that lecture that's all he talked about
no you didn't paint our at all right
but table bases are interesting because
we learn a lot about rook and pawn
endings my favorite is this one now you
all know the Philidor position now I'm
kidding
none of you anything okay I'm sorry I
teased you so the fluid or position
assuming black is going this way this is
the typical drawing position white does
nothing and eventually black doesn't
want to make any illegal move so he
plays here so he can play this and win
and then white loses rook down and
starts giving checks and as a draw well
sometimes you can't achieve the Philidor
position so you have other choices to
make so you have a position like this
let us say and you got to have your King
skedaddle
you know movie so you'll get mated and
then sometimes it's a win sometimes to
draw and while Magnus Carlsen for
example had one of these drawn positions
and now he's well known to mess up these
drawn positions and lose but he had one
a few years ago and he lost and it was a
draw and I said I know what I'm going to
do I'm going to set up these positions
and put them on the table base I don't
know how to draw them it'll show me the
drawing technique but that's incorrect
because a lot of things draw and they're
just sort of random it's like
everything's a draw so it makes moves
the draw that sort of make it harder to
draw but not harder for the table base
which sees every legal move so it
doesn't say this is the only way to draw
this is only explains it it just says
these all draw then when I make them
it's like y'all these moves draw and I'm
like God I know there's no pattern I
don't know what to do so I don't know
whether I should go here or whether I
should go here although I do know but
once I do make the right move I still
don't know what to do I think this is
the right movie right Spence yeah there
you go and then you know I'll still lose
this even though it's a draw yeah